sur notre notre forum andré quelqu'un
qui nous demande nous amène sur un autre
chemin totalement qui nous parle de la
france qui présente dans ces lois sur la
transition énergétique qui a été adoptée
par le parlement en juillet
l'obsolescence programmée qui devient
une infraction punie de deux ans de
prison et de trois cent mille euros
d'amendé
alors pourquoi ne pas faire la même
chose au québec et au canada
alors est-ce que également jeu pour
élargir est ce que c'est un mythe
le sol et sans ce programme et où c'est
un fait dont madame lessard je crois que
c'est un peu pour ça j'ai suivi un cours
la session dernière au printemps dernier
avec fabien durif qui est responsable de
l'observatoire consommation responsable
c'est un nos collaborateurs aussi rhodes
premièrement l'obsolescence programmée
ça serait un mythe c'est à dire qu'on va
parler d'une obsolescence relative parce
que programmer implique un espèce
d'esprit machiavélique derrière les
choses puis que tout d'un coup mon
ordinateur d'un interrupteur ou là il ya
un filet et ça a explosé lorsque c'est
la fin c'est programmé un telle date tel
un messie c'est pas vrai c'est pas comme
ça que ça fonctionne par contre oui il
ya une espèce de culture de
l'obsolescence relative qui est de
concevoir des produits qui sont de moins
en moins performants ou de moins en
moins durable c'est à dire que souvent
il va avoir une pièce qui va qui tu vas
être membre depuis pas de pierres mais
de moindre qualité puis c'est bien connu
des électroménagers les gros électro les
frigos et où là c'est une durée de vie
de 8 à 10 ans oui faudrait que ça c'est
une grotte problématique et c'est
d'ailleurs dans la nuit de la recherche
on s'intéresse de plus en plus à ce
phénomène là parce que ça n'a jamais été
prouvée lequel existe vraiment une
obsolescence programmée comme je sais
une obsolescence relative qui est en
place il ya énormément de choses à
regarder justement dans le monde puis
d'essayer de prendre des exemples je
pense que des fois au lieu de réinventer
la roue ben on regarde ce qui se passe
ailleurs on voit c'est quoi les facteurs
de succès et les choses à éviter qu'ils
n'ont pas bien marché c'est de rapporter
ça donc je sais pas si ça répond en
partie à la question est est-ce qu'on
n'a pas aussi des comportements par
exemple
ce que les gens pourraient faire un
effort davantage pour faire réparer des
choses ça c'est la culture en fait on
peut s'en aller vers un autre géant ne
la culture de l'efficience on dit qu'il
faut être plus performant on va avoir
des projets des produits plus
technologique qui va être mieux conçus
et tout et tout mais il ya la notion
aussi de suffisance qu on dit qu'on
oublie bien souvent et cette
surconsommation la l'obsolescence
programmée il vient aussi ou relative
vient aussi de ce cette surconsommation
leur tête c'est que c'est comme ça on
décide de s'attaquer au problème via on
va concevoir des produits durablement
mais d'un autre côté on a de la
difficulté à avoir un regard sur notre
consommation qu'on on le sait on
surconsomme pas qu'il ya des questions
des débats philosophiques de sociétés à
se poser davantage croix pour parce
qu'en parlant on va dire avant de régler
le problème comme ça si on prend pas le
temps de comprendre pourquoi on
surconsomme pourquoi cette notion de
suffisance là elle fait pas partie de
notre façon d'évoluer
je pense qu'on va passer à côté de
quelque chose et en 2015 c'est difficile
d'acheter l'appareil ménager qui a été
construit dans les années 80 et qui
tuerait 35 ans donc on édition conduit
exactement la réparation c'est qu'on
n'est pas non plus dans la culture de la
réparation c'est comme soi que j'achète
j' ai je fait réparer mon frigo ça va
nous coûter 300 de l'argent n'achète pas
un usage et ça va me coûter 200 $ il ya
quelque chose qui est un non sens et que
les gens disposent oui à toute une
culture à revoir l'action